the superlatives coming out of the
weekend that was only one game to talk
about Chris superlatives from Super Bowl
53 you get the first one well you look
tired Mike just everybody there on Sky
Sports Mike's been up all night okay I
just want to make sure they knew what
you really look like it's a tired Monday
for you I just wanted to make sure
everybody knew about that Thanks um no
problem okay I think my suit my first
superlatives re if I could have to try
it out there you had a little trouble
there yeah
would be at least I have an excuse I'm
tired hey why not coaches that's my
superlative right there why not coaches
and what I mean and I buy this is I
think if there was ever a game this is a
to parts I got for you here
why not coaches there was ever a game
for the head coach to become the MVP of
the game like Bill Belichick should have
got it last night that should have been
the MVP one okay yes because look at
what they did the Rams a high power team
we saw this wasn't about great Jimmy's
and Joe's winning the Super Bowl matchup
last night between the Patriots and the
RAM it wasn't about the Jimmy's and
Joe's it was about the X's and O's once
again by Bill Belichick and 2-part I
don't know how I feel about a guy who
was suspended for the first four games
of the year for performance-enhancing
drugs and his defense for what happened
with the drug test was I'm not really
sure I don't know how I feel about that
about the ghaib now being the Super Bowl
MVP who obviously did something he was
not supposed to so it's a weird dynamic
for me you know I my little boy asked me
last night why was Julian Edelman
suspended for the first four games of
the year this year somebody had told him
that online as he was playing Madden at
halftime or whatever and I have to
explain them well son he took
performance-enhancing drugs what are
that oh these things they make your
muscles bigger grow that's why he wins
the MVP so I don't know how I feel about
that I'm not sure the NFL doesn't need
to step in in these instances and maybe
not even let that happen because I know
that's a rule and Major League Baseball
what one thing that definitely happens
for a guy who's been suspended for peds
he's not eligible for any of the you
know the
Pro Bowl or the either related awards
that come out of that but he's eligible
to play in the postseason he's eligible
to win the MVP award a look I look at it
this way whatever caused him to get
suspended for those four games the end
result is enhanced testing I'd like to
think he's clean now that's right yeah
cuz he's he's tested far more frequently
than anyone would have been say we can
assume that what we saw last night was a
guy who isn't pharmaceutically enhanced
beyond whatever supplements the NFL
allows but Chris this is the second time
for the Patriots to have the MVP of the
Super Bowl
be a guy who was suspended the first
four weeks of the season yeah two years
ago
Super Bowl 51 Tom Brady was suspended
for the first four games due to the the
final outcome of the deflategate yeah
controversy and now two years later
Edelman missed the first four games I
joke last night hey okay 2016 Brady
misses four games he's the MVP of the
Super Bowl 2018 Edelman misses four
games he's the MVP of the Super Bowl in
2020 the Patriots players are gonna be
chugging liquid steroids in the hopes of
missing the first four games of the
season well that's the formula to be the
Super Bowl MVP
I hear ya I hear ya and I really do
think I know what do you I know what you
mean I'm Joe I know you're joking I
think the big thing too is like I do
think that there was ever a game or a
coach I mean come on that was
unbelievable here we were Chris go ahead
what its its MVP its MVP most valuable
player most nice person I okay well they
have to change it to a different P right
if as long as it's most valuable player
your arguments not going anywhere
I guess trade-ins the whole thing the
most valuable individual most valuable
personal yeah and I think under that
scenario the coach does get
consideration but that would just be
weird
that if the coach would be in the same
bucket as the players then again they're
in the same bucket as the players for
getting into the Hall of Fame so maybe
they should be that's what I'm saying I
mean we break rules all the time I mean
why not I don't understand why it's it's
okay I'm just saying that was a rare
instance and where we saw the greatest
coach of all time in the year of okay
how ironic is it the year of Oh
offensive explosion and points points
points touchdowns points fantasy oh this
is awesome
and Bill
balichek says three points in the Super
Bowl sorry negative ghostrider I know
how to coach though I just think it was
an amazing performance by him that's
really what I wanted to shed light on
and of course a little bit on the
Edelman situation as well how much of
it's him and how much of it is the de
facto defensive coordinator Brian Flores
who as of today
assuming they let him get out of the
building will be the head coach of the
Miami Dolphins well I think Brian Flores
is a very he's a top-notch football
coach you've heard me wax poetically
about him the last few weeks he's
amazing and I think a lot of it is him
he comes up with the gameplan a lot of
the nuts and bolts of that game plan and
then Belichick tweaks and questions it
and does things from there but Flores
certainly deserves a lot of the credit
and hey we saw a step up in their
defense this year you know yeah okay
maybe they were a little more talented
than last year but I you know hey it's
hard to argue that Brian Flores you know
didn't do a better job than the new head
coach of the Detroit Lions Matt Patricia
did last year there was an improvement
with that Patriots defense well and that
is amazing too when you consider what
the Eagles and Nick Foles did to the
Patriots last year and what Sean McVeigh
Jared Goff and the Rams weren't able to
do this year all right this feels like a
title you would use I think I've been
hanging around you too much I'm starting
to talk like you I'm starting to act
like you yeah you would call this the
johnny-on-the-spot award because it
doesn't have a whole lot of creativity
it's fairly obvious johnny-on-the-spot
award goes to Jason McCourty who you
know for all of the things that the MV
person did by putting together that game
plan there was a point in the third
quarter when the Rams were down three
nothing and Brandon cooks sprung wide
open and he was at the back of the end
zone and there was a touchdown and Jason
McCord he gets over and blows it up and
prevents the Rams from getting that
touchdown and that wasn't even his guy
but he saw what was going on and he got
over and disrupted it cooks wide open
now golf waited too long to throw it but
McCourty got over and made that play and
you use you make that a touchdown that
changes everything for the rest of the
game that adds pressure to the Patriots
maybe they
make a mistake on their next drive and
the next thing you know it goes from 7
to 3 to 10 to 3 or 14 to 3 and that the
whole game changes potentially if
McCourty does not make that play well
that's what makes them amazing they get
these players that are so they have
great football IQ and intelligence and
there they are yeah you're right wasn't
really necessarily Jason McCord ease
area but he's realized there was a
deficiency or a hole in the defense and
I'm gonna cover up for it I played
enough football I'm smart
Belichick Brian floors have taught me so
much and what to look for and what to
read for so not only was he Johnnie spot
on the spot that play hey he's Johnny on
the spot about to get a new ring - good
job by him joining his brother up there
and of course getting his first Super
Bowl ring that's a pretty cool
experience for that family in general
and they're great people I've known them
since they were very young they played
against my brother in high school so
couldn't be happy enough for those two
really because they they live what they
preach they work hard they love the
sport so that's really cool okay this
has to be I got to do it because it
might be my last chance to do it all
year but we're gonna build a wall we're
gonna build a wall and Robert Kraft is
gonna pay for it because that goes
through the New England Patriots okay
because what they did this playoff wall
that they created Mike I mean whoa I
don't care if it was concrete slots
barriers whatever it was really awesome
I'm having fun I guess is really did to
you I'm really determined to do this
today aren't well I just thought it'd be
fun but the Patriots come on that was
this is an unbelievable performance by
their offensive line once again I mean
not only in the run game but all we
worried about was Donald su are they
gonna ruin the game and they went
through the Chargers the Chiefs and the
Rams the best pass rushing D lines the
sport has to offer and none of them
touch Tom Brady Franklin the only guy
with a sack yesterday I mean sue and
Donnell basically unheard of it just
speaks not only once again to the great
coaching of Dante scar Nekia the
offensive line coach of the New England
Patriots who like Bill Belichick said
this week is probably the greatest
offensive line coach
history the NFL but the the guys they've
accumulated up there it's a talented
group and once again just another
example of New England zigging why the
rest of the league is sagging oh you're
getting the spread offense you get all
these cool you know young hipster
offensive coaches to be your head coach
but I don't think these defensive guys
have seen Smash Mouth pulling guard in a
long time and Belichick's decided to go
that route and here they are of course
the champions of football once again on
that point don't you think the Bengals
are at least wondering today whether or
not they should take advantage of the
fact that there isn't an official deal
with Rams quarterbacks coach Zack Taylor
and hey maybe look in a different
direction maybe this whole hey he's a
friend of Shawn McVeigh's he's worked
with Shawn McVeigh's maybe that's not
the magic bullet that that we thought it
was well I mean this is the day where
they're going hey I know Shawn McVeigh
but that was his game play and I didn't
come up with that all right for you this
one is the it's not a lie if you believe
an award because I'm so sick of hearing
this no one believed in the Patriots no
I'm Bill Belichick last night when they
got the trophy we were they counted us
out from the start of the season who
everybody know they didn't but they only
listen to what they want to listen to
they only hear what they want to hear
and they only believe what they want to
believe and it works
so yes it's a bunch of crap but they've
convinced themselves it's true so it
doesn't matter it's not a lie if you
believe it and they believe that people
out there didn't believe in them they
believe that people didn't pick them to
get to the Super Bowl or win the Super
Bowl
they believe that you and I didn't pick
them to win the Super Bowl they ignore
the voices that favor them they obsess
over the voices that doubt them and
they've made it work and I guarantee you
already they're thinking about next year
because the Chiefs are the favorites to
win Super Bowl 54 not the team that just
won their six Super Bowl and all they're
not they don't believe in us already for
next year and it's going to continue and
continue and continue as long as they
can convince themselves that it's the
truth even when it isn't yeah that I
mean this is a Patriots team that was
chippy er than normal
I mean they took things a little bit
more personal I almost want to say this
is like a similar to that Patriots team
who beat the you know the Eagles with
Rodney Harrison and company who were a
little chippy and found any way or
anything possible really to motivate
themselves whether you know I can
remember Rodney Harrison getting the
interception and doing the eagle's wings
cuz you know they were frustrated and
sick of seeing the Eagles and the
offense and Terrell Owens and all those
things I also think you know to your
point right Mike I mean I don't know I
don't remember seeing Bill Belichick so
relaxed the Saturday walked through the
families went Friday declaring the team
was ready to go yesterday on the podium
I mean that was his like as jubilant as
I've ever seen Bill Belichick I mean so
that to me I think also tells you he had
a team he trusted and was motivated and
did the things that he wanted on a
consistent basis and that's why there's
a Super Bowl champs yeah well I think he
also knew that after two weeks of
studying what the Rams do they knew
exactly what needed to be done and they
were highly confident they'd be able to
pull it off yeah no doubt we got we got
time for more supporters yeah well like
the don't forget about us I'm gonna give
them a gift don't forget about us award
or whatever the hell you want to call it
here I want to talk about the Rams
defense they played phenomenal football
I mean they really did but what happened
the nightmare of what we talked about a
little last week right Mike and the
thing that I worried about certainly the
Rams defense being on the field too much
and in the first half they were on the
field twice as much as the Patriots
defense and then there we were late in
the fourth quarter and we couldn't we
never heard Dante Fowler Aaron Donald
not and Omikron Sue's name not for one
second
they couldn't get by close to Brady in
any of the big moments to create a big
play or do any of that and not only goes
to the coaching but again the offensive
line but still this Rams defense
deserves a lot of credit
holding the New England Patriots the
offense which has one of the best run
games I've seen in a long time
and really slowing down the pass offense
for the most part of the day other than
just not having an answer for Julian
Edelman and a few big plays
they played phenomenal and like you said
to start the show I think if McVeigh
said oh the rent that Patriots scored 13
points then we got a chance to win this
football game and of course that wasn't
the case
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports